greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday March 27 this podcast is
brought to you by CBD Lion picking a
reliable CBD company was like pulling
[__] teeth no more they got 80 brands
on that but lucky for you [__]
I found CBD Lyon if you're gonna CBD
Lyon calm and check out that third party
lab results you're gonna be [__]
amazing right now the church family gets
20% off at checkout when you put in
church CH you are CH at checkout that's
Church CH you are CH CBD Lyon the
reliable CBD company also let me ask you
something you're starting to lose your
hair a little bit maybe sometimes you go
on a date and things that the plumbing
ain't working like your usual let me
tell ya I got something for you company
called hims
it's a wellness brand for men you've
heard us talk about it for years now but
let me explain something is 66% of men
start to lose their hair by the age of
35 and once you know this you got
thinning hair it's too late is that hell
I'm slowly starting to move backwards
any bald spots yet I got the solution
for hems dot-com a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care and sexual wellness
if you know what I'm talking about
listen you got no snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements
prescriptions solutions backed by
science that's what I'm talking about so
what I'm gonna do is get the church
started the church family started with
hims complete hair kit for 5 hours today
while supplies last subject to doctor's
approval and restrictions apply see the
website for full detail this could cost
you hundreds if you went to a doctor or
a pharmacy or some other guy from the
street no no no at for hims calm we got
your coverage so go to forums comm slash
Joey that's for hims calm slash Joey and
see how hims can help you the podcast is
also brought to you by listen zip
recruiter you know a challenging install
hire the right candidate for the right
job it takes a long time too many
applicants and now zip recruit it makes
it easy
hiring is challenging what are you gonna
do since recruiter sends your jumped
over a hundred of the web's leading job
woods but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans through thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience to invite them to apply for
your job who else does that
zip recruiter analyzes each one in
spotlights the top candidates so stop
messing around whether you got a small
business or a large corporation or
whatever you've got zip recruiter is the
way to go and right now the church
listeners can get zip recruiter for free
free2play serve address you ready grab a
pen
zip recruiter comms last Church again
that zip recruited dot-com slash Church
si-hu rch zip mccoullough dot-com slash
Church kick this [__] melee are
you [__] kidding me Mike Tyson on how
hard does this hit this is eighty
something just I come out to my fights
in this song yeah this makes you want to
stab come out all the buzz how the
radical of the youngster oh my god Mike
you did something that happens in
Hollywood but it happened to you you
will like the [__] king at the age of
20 how hard was I mean you don't even
know what the [__] was going on around
no absolutely sure but 20 things are
moving so fast hey young well he never
thought about that me and this old tiny
fella we got together and he has told me
these wonderful things about myself and
what I could accomplish if I listened to
him and so I dedicated my life and
listened to him and listening to him now
did he take you to a hypnotist yeah he
was everything but he also took me to
one he was able assist yeah in which way
um yes they were um allow you to relax
and he can reach your subconsciousness
with the tone of his voice
yeah and just talk to you nice and light
yeah yeah yeah
cus was a weird breed yeah I never met
him got arrested so every but he knew
what he wanted in life you wanted
champions you know Mike I want to write
a book I've been writing a book but in
that book in between chapters I'm gonna
write about the people who touch my life
in the wind how many [__] came
in and out of your life that you think
about every three days and go god and
then I'm dead I'm not even talking about
that they'd still be alive you're just
in a difference mind game you didn't
talk a little no more yeah
you're not talking I don't know more
because it most of my dad is not like
[__] my life is change how many
[__] came up to you one day
didn't want none from you and just says
some to you then you went back to your
room and had to think about what the
[__] this happened and you look back and
they disappear and you think that maybe
could be an angel from God that just I
had 20 [__] that have come into
my life at the weirdest times and they
disappeared
I want to write like a page just in
between chapters how many [__]
do you have that really affected you in
the weirdest ways you know wow we said a
lot of people in my life that affect me
in the particular way they easily passed
away stuff and I'm I was watching a
documentary about Joan Rivers Joseph
Joan Rivers she's the blonde [__] oh
right right a crazy lady yeah and she
had somebody left her she goes to
contact one of her working and she said
God he was there and you know what that
means remember when this happened it's
weird I'm not even talking like I got a
guy that lives him there's no ammo Beach
and one day I was he was my sales
manager of a car place and he was trying
to hang me out I think it's time for you
to travel my stop and dog ain't no
[__] comedian I'm a criminal car
salesman I barely keep it together I
didn't notice at this time I didn't know
there's someone day I sold the car that
night late
they were washing it the next morning
and the kids son why I went back to the
checkout on my one of this condom would
be ready by night and the kids sound
like the mangas funny we were talking
about it this morning at breakfast he
goes my dad said if it had any balls he
quit his job get the card take you on
the road to do comedy that [__] [__]
my insides up like yeah like till this
day I check in with him once every two
months
he's about 70 he's the one that taught
me how to write my gold he used to say a
lot of people go you know like no write
down I want to be world champion well
how are you gonna become world champion
right now the things you need to do to
become world champion
I got a tray and I can't drink I gotta
stay away from these people and he would
make you write weekly goals daily goals
like when you went in there and everyday
he wouldn't let you talk to a customer
until you write down your goals for the
week I'm gonna sell myself
two cars today I'm gonna call ten people
on the phone I'm going to talk to eight
people face to face I'm gonna have a
good attitude you gotta hand it to him
he ain't dead but I never forgot that
lesson he came into my lifetime yeah
yeah yeah we still talk I talk to the
kids online the one can have shares a
birthday with me so I wish them happy
birthday short I don't forget nobody
like that came into my life like an
angel my prison counselor redneck
[__] Mike Mike the first a sat
down like I wanted to you know you just
get off the bus when you go to prison
yeah and then shackle you and they give
you the [__] towel and your sheets
and then you go to the room and then
some [__] comes to this is Tyson
council wants to see your room for and
you got to go in there and before you
even sit a Mike before I even sat down
he goes Oh before you sit on my taser
I don't like [__] [__] and Jews so I
don't like you already Mike that was out
a conversation open man I'm going in
there with personality like that [__]
that [__] that know
he said to me did you ever get sit down
no he goes don't even sit down I don't
like this these type of minorities I'm
not crazy about Chinese be like he just
he was a redneck with a military hairdo
Oh crazy he goes I read over your report
you you got here my Skinner your [__]
mother's [__] and then he goes you just
do this list and before I hit the door
he goes you ever get hepatitis C or
something
it was either hepatitis or some other
disease I don't know he goes report to
the kitchen you got a job get the [__]
out of my sight so for weeks I didn't
like him like you know how can I like a
guy that opens up like that only likes
breaks what a [__] you nobody's ever
said that [__] to me but somehow or
another he got impressed with me you
know I did what I was supposed to do and
there was these psychological
evaluations you know when we first got
locked up before we they sent this tour
on destination they do that week where
they ask you stupid questions they draw
blood they ask you to [__] fill the
circles with the blocks did you have to
do that yeah a whole week and they
wouldn't it look like this yes like yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's that sir III watched the year
Spike Lee documentary it was it blew my
mind how similar you two were but it
said you were arrested 38 times by the
10 or 13 yeah like do they even do
Diagnostics anymore and after like 30
times
they give you Thorazine and with that
medication that the kid really they
drive with some lubricant well Mike and
I were kids there was there was with iam
door zine and then there was a heavy one
that gave you a nice to call it the
lithium shuffle soon as you go to prison
they give you Thorazine to calm you down
dangerous guy and you have to take it
yeah and then what you doing yeah and
then what you do is you double up on
them like I'll put them under my tongue
and save them until I got three of them
is that eat them all at once again [__]
15 sometimes you just sell them sapphire
yeah uses I want something in me they
always make sure like it they're under
your tongue and [__] like that it's a
complete so you do that diagnostic and
at the end of that diagnostic report
they make an assessment and that
assessment goes to the [__] FBI and
every other Federal Bureau this is their
assessment and I gotta tell you it's
it's an I believe it's an 87% assessment
because it was big amongst the prisoners
they would say did you get your report
yet and you had a you had a file a
petition to a lawyer to actually get it
yeah mine I was like a [__] [__]
and [__] no it did yeah no it did he
told me I was a [__] they don't want
you to know the result they didn't
really want you to know so once I got
under his skin
once he became my buddy kind of sorted
even though I know he is minorities I
would go up to him when I was walking go
blue his name was mr. blue blue blue
what are you gonna give me the
diagnostic report he said get the [__]
out of his big boy like he was say [__]
like that with a giggle and I was
already used to that from Jersey miss
Dottie no so he couldn't by when I was a
kid there was a dude on my corner and he
used to say [__] to me every day and I
love them to death because he toughened
me up he you know if they knew I did
Santeria so every time I walked up the
corner hey what are you your mother
gonna invite some black people up and
jump up and down and kill chickens
tonight [__] I could mean he was but he
was say [__] to the Irish he was say
[__] to the Jews everybody he made a
comment from his [__] balcony so I
made this guy out to be like mr. t no
and finally like a month before I got
out I went up to him like I missed mr.
blue tell me what it said on that day
and he's like you don't want to know did
I hear you gotta tell me what it says on
there and he got pissed he walked me
into his office he threw
[__] foul on the table and he goes it
says and then if I had something you
wanted you would take her from me that's
what it says that you're a [__] thief
that what you wanted to know and Mike I
broke Mike I'd rather have you punch me
in the stomach anytime and the feeling I
had at that moment because at 25 years
old I was told that I was gonna not to
amount to anything else but a [__]
common thief that's devastating and he
told me this four days before Christmas
like you're ruined my [__] Christmas
but at least I came to terms with I go
from be a thief I'm gonna be the best
[__] thief there isn't I got a little
wrong yeah and I always had you know
coming from places like booking people
just it makes you feel real bad about
this okay it's just like you're you're a
predator and everybody outside of
Brooklyn's prey and you looked at funny
you know watch out for him he's gonna
try to rob he's up for it in your house
keep your doors closed and we had that
reputation but we always had a bad
reputation you know before we the
podcast we were talking about how there
was a time in 1984 while I became a
[__] animal and I became such an
animal I would keep her from my friends
like the kids I grew up with I would
keep it from my friends you know I was
working in Manhattan at the Sheridan
Center on 52nd and seventh and I got out
at 1:00 in the morning
you know what that's like for a 20 to 21
year old kid with 200 hours in this
pocket a half gram of blood just to get
the party started and have beautiful oh
no no it's beautiful I was the king of
New York but I did [__] those nights
that you know from that one on for like
18 months of nights
I still remember being at a [__]
party might like they invite us after a
club like the rooftop you remember the
rooftop very well you want in there
after 11:00 and it was $17 all you could
drink and after three it was $14 all you
could drink and we went home with Paul
Newman's door
like I was that like not the [__]
we all were dying in yeah like it was
like a party she Alec got an apartment
we had different floors not every floor
there were people slunk off you were
talking to people and I ended up in a
bedroom with a friend of mine and this
girl I would I school with both of them
what rivers had grown up together and
what's not in Coke and we got that a
Tuesday now it's Wednesday and now it's
Thursday morning was still romantic okay
MacDonald five writes live nobody's in
coach drinking every still up baby the
way thinking about [__] you dick [__]
every time you pee you get-a toilet
paper you wash your dick yeah just in
case somebody decides to suck it you
don't want it to smell like pee and
helmet just made [__] up and I wanted
to [__] this girl but she was our friend
I knew she was a dirty [__] but our
friendship was bigger than us to me
trying to [__] her on the coat but one
night well this morning he was like
eleven in the morning
my buddies we were there so long they
towed my buddy's car that's how you know
you're somewhere too long so was
Thursday morning and when the thing and
all of a sudden we're looking for a
lighter and lubbers go look in the
drawer and Regina opens the drawer and
there's a [__] Elsa [__] coke like
my bad it's like heaven yes and I look
it up and look at how it opened up I'm
looking Regina I go Regina take
something we'll get the [__] outta you
she's like take some I'm taking it all
she put in her purse we walked out of
there we had no cash to get back to
Jersey
Luke went upstairs and borrowed money to
get his car run towed this is this is
when the eighties this is the New York
was [__] crazy
or this had to be yeah eighty-five what
were you an 85 85
establish and just turned professional
fighter fighting anything year though
this kind of fighting will you smoking
reefer that I smoked a little weed
that's that when I started fighting for
the Olympics they would test you yeah so
you couldn't smoke over there
when did you start local we've got 97
that's 98 97 start smoking back and it
calms you down hey lad was smoking the
one I wouldn't smoke the ones my fight
had an awesome fire [__] the guy a
broken cheekbone the eye socket isn't
his joy back where the [__] man a
[__] with the red yeah yeah but the
armed if they find me three hundred
thousand all they tested you afterwards
yeah oh so they really look at marijuana
as an enhancement drumming yeah I
believe sadly these that is [__]
crazy but I tell you what the best thing
I ever did growing up with shooting
hoops and there was nothing like
shooting hoops when you stoned to the
[__] gills to play basket like train
box inspiring Jimmy yes no no no I'll do
bag work I'll jump rope I'll do
kettlebells
I'll lift punches getting thrown at me
when I'm stoned
ah [__] you at jujitsu I'd never even
think about getting hard before I'm
[__] good it relaxes you when you're
sparring there it takes that look see I
like it before going on stage before I
go on stage the feeling you get it all
lives in your stomach everything that
you own everything they get what I will
not say that got nothing going this over
I couldn't go on stage all right let me
ask you this off the [__] coffee i
watch Tyson I watched you go do a
one-man show and I think he came on HBO
yes i sat there going this man what he's
done but then I go to him this is dead
because he's beating people up in front
of eighteen fifty thousand people with a
million people watching you on
pay-per-view what's the difference of
what I mean you went up there like you
were you have been doing stand-up for 20
years it's different
Stephan no I um it's too [__]
intimate you know to implement that I'd
to block out you know they'll say I'm
fighting you can block everything out
but you can still see removes everything
fly
down you know but right there is just
too [__] poor you turn around and
your [__] face
so um it's very interesting how that I
was doing that nobody but I put it all
in the same perspective this fighting
when you went up on stage yeah [__]
brilliant because I've been telling
people that ever since I started you
Jitsu my stand-up game has gotten way
[__] better I've become a better
stand up now I know when to breathe now
I know when to attack yeah yeah now I
know how to beat him up for a reset
three minutes and backing off fearless
they pretty exhilarating when it gives
you something of a high in a state when
you got off stage what did you feel my
god I'll stay that I felt that I need to
get back on stage
really yeah now where did you rehearse
this in Vegas and MGM Grand
how many times did you rehearse this a
week with you before you shot it for HBO
um Wow we did it for a long time and
then they said let's go to Broadway
first they took of the Broadway and then
once we did it in Broadway and I shoot
it here maybe shot it there how long was
it on Broadway for um I think we did two
weeks would you switch the stories up
every night or did you stayed to a um
something else pops up yes like
sometimes you between two stories and
you got the two stories but there's a
bridge between those [__]
stories that'll make those stories so
much just a little changes always change
and how did you feel when you got off
stage were you tired were you vulnerable
no um I thought it wasn't long with him
I need to get back on there again I
wanted to be out there I want people to
see me I want them Claude more and stuff
and how long would you do how long was
the original this I used to do it twice
a day and twice a year if I did it twice
the dancing shows and who wrote it with
you my wife wrote it
no [__] and you just told her the story
she told what happened first
whoa I don't talk about that you think
you know that I said no baby everybody
knows I lied people out they were single
I [__] they know everybody know
what happened that that's like to tell
Julie but no no one could compensate
that's [__] you know that really
would happen
you didn't care like me like I don't
give a [__] wait all out there anybody
knows I know but you know I told
everybody before I'm talking about your
stage like there babe I know oh yeah
like I was telling me yesterday
the other night to get on stage and
sometimes Lee might feel like I'm
bullying him or whatever but what I'm
trying to explain to Lee is the more you
go onstage the more you peel the layers
off I can make you go up there talk [__]
for every night for a year until one
night you're [__] dying and also you
don't you start talking about [__] this
let me tell you what I had when I saw
when I was four I was walking around the
block I saw it dude stab another do an
awesome looks crowd is silent but all
sudden you just took off your shirt you
just put your heart in their hands and
that's a weird
it took me [__] 11 years of comedy
they even think of putting prison drug
addiction the pain had grown up finding
my mother dead on the [__] floor when
I'm gonna hit an acid it took years for
me to come up on stage and get the balls
to say that because I didn't think it
was interesting I thought that everybody
took these lumps I thought - after
everybody kept it in fact I thought I
felt dirty about the right to feel dirty
hold my tongue my childhood was that was
poor I feel real bad about that and it
was just really bad it's like no this is
never gonna turn out good there's no way
I was gonna become this kind I am now
for how long didn't you feel it for how
long did it take you to not feel the
real Mike Tyson like for me I had to be
I was 44 years old when I fell - Joey
Diaz was I was there like I broke this F
break I broken listened to three
chapters my
my birth name is Jose Antonio Diaz
that's my [__] slave man I gave
you before they put me out of this [__]
my street name is Coco Diaz and my name
today is Joey Diaz
and I've had to for me to keep going
I've had to break this up into three
characters understand who the [__] made
me do you feel that way like at one time
you were little Mike tough my dirty my
dirty Mike okay you were dirty Mike and
then you became the undisputed champion
of the world that's right
then you became dirty crazy Mike now
these men came a fool then you became
nasty yeah full nasty Mike that West win
of NWA
you know I'm saying like you were that W
I really didn't hurt anybody with myself
really you know we have had a lot of fun
I bought a lot of cars with people and
girls and stuff and we spend their money
on boats and cars houses playing
whatever get in and travel yeah give a
[__]
where the next dollar was coming from
you know I mean it's coming off it
didn't come you could still Robin no I
mean a Walkman so you know yeah we make
90 a year so we just gone crazy 90
million dollars when did the bloke come
into this Wow you can blow - what 2006
probably oh okay that came later when
you were champion you were champion yeah
on every time yeah did you when you were
growing up being dirty Mike did you
think drugs are gonna be a part of your
life huh
none when you were hanging out with cus
that was the farthest thing for me
mother hanging out with cus yeah I'm
over drugs always been a part of my life
and I thought yeah my mother alcohol my
father drug addict stuff I get to play
and stuff so um I always did Joseph I
wanted to do boxing so bad I gave all
that stuff up you really
respected your son you never thought you
knew drugs again while you were knocking
[__] out of 20 no I always
think I wanna smoke a joint oh you did
at least wanna smoke a joint but I was
drinking like a fish though so I my mind
works like this this is how my mind
works at ten nine eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen this time I want listen I'm not
gonna do weed and no more drugs no
wacker that's illegal but I'm gonna get
drunk like a mother for I was alcoholic
my whole career oh man play the [__]
full-blown Oh what am i doing training
here no I didn't do that stuff during my
training but listen I have to fight that
I'm a monster
right to the bars for how long huh how
long would you go after your till we got
a next fightin I start training again
saying something before that was
interesting
when you I mean here you are gonna get
[__] champions or beat people up now
you have to I consider when I go up on
stage that I'm going up in front of a
mirror and that's why you get those
nerves sometimes you were saying that
before you got out of stage your nerves
would be out of [__] control you
needed to get blasted why no I have to
me um
I'm not comfortable enough of myself
being sober and performing like that
from all the people I have to have to
get stimulated what kind of pre-show
stimulation the jab you know you shout
about the smoke smoke low to joint like
an hour before 15 minutes 30 minutes
before I gonna stage and how loose did
it make you feel
yeah it's ready to go I'm tritium and
then hit me when you get offstage after
an hour hour how long was the 1:15
yeah 1:15 when you got off did you feel
that night when you get to the hotel
that pain but a little discomfort in
your thighs because you were you were
for me when I get on stage and this has
just been the last 10 years when I
learned how
become a headliner when I became a
headliner yeah I was headlining clubs
but I wasn't [__] a headliner
there's a big difference sometimes my
legs feel sore after two shows because
I'm gripping my feet like a [__]
animal into the ground and I'm letting
everything going I ain't backing up
[__] in my mind I'm like this is what I
do just no no go go go home if I haven't
been doing shorts call a year because I
won't do a show less I'm in
hundred-percent physical shape
god bless I'm on stage why huh why
because my stage there is a lot of
energy it was explosive I'm doing stuff
jumping all over the place I'm moving a
lot and I can't do that I can't do that
right now my show I can do my show right
today I'm furnace or whatever to tie I
can finish the show when I do two shows
now like I do two shows a night and I
[__] by the third second night some
and I work on the daytime you know I'm
saying honey on the elliptical 20
minutes awaits I'm an old man I ain't
looking there's a kickboxing school I'll
take the hour class and stuff like that
but I do agree with you when I was 400
pounds and I was going up on stage when
I get off stage there'd be two puddles
under my arm
the cocaine would be sweating a night
before because I would never do coke
before I wanna I'm not you gotta get I'm
only got a dick I did coke instead you
want that then turn right in like oh oh
[__] is it [__] about my nose do not
wanna do coke talking [__] through my
nose I like to know I did it one time
st. Patty's Day 1992 that was the last
time I did cocaine before I won today I
couldn't even do cocaine at 1:00 in the
afternoon if I had a show at 8:00 now
don't get me wrong while I was up on
stage you know I had a gram in that drug
pocket Hoan because as soon as I get off
stage before I can talk to Mike Tyson or
Joey la Bamba or give Lee a hug I would
go hold on I got a P because I had to
keep that adrenaline going so I would
was paying I would do my first three
bumps then I come out and give you a hug
and then I was Joey that's it
that was that was how it was for the
last ten years of my interview I had to
have it in my pocket I don't want no
problems if you told me it was on its
way I went up on stage and that would be
cracked because I didn't have it I
wanted my pocket I don't want to do it
just give it to me let me hold it in my
pocket
don't make me feel comfortable that that
was the reason why it took me so long to
quit cocaine because I didn't think I'd
be funny but I knew one thing when I
went up on stage coat down like the
night before like if I'd done coke for
two nights in a row that next time when
I get on stage I would tell you material
but my soul and my heart wasn't
connecting with the material and what I
want to say after everybody knows I'm
cocaine you did a bugbear I got Mike so
you had to break down your life so we're
still the dirty Mike Mike and who are
you today
listen Rayna just one establish my
relationship with my children now you
know me and my wife are cool now we
don't bees no we don't fight we work at
the team now but pretty much
establishing my relationship my sons and
stuff Linda knows all about sacrificing
and yes you know dedicating your life to
something that you really want to
achieve something in and then after that
maybe if they achieve your goal then you
hang around a party and have fun but you
have to establish yourself first before
even you know I tend even enjoy myself
erm when I first understood what I've
sacrificed were than what this what the
prize is was just from sacrifice
I couldn't imagine I wouldn't achieve
things in life and we came very um
what's the word very ambitious the young
kid I can't understand and 2018-19 I've
established so much my kids they like
that kind of drive I wasn't have that
drivable
themselves when you think is missing
from kids today having that drive at 20
that we had grown up yeah I didn't stop
yeah well I let me say I don't know
maybe it's mindful maybe I'm are
pampering them maybe I think I think me
and I think we allowed them to have
everything they needed at the young kid
and probably a little bit more they able
to go go out the country and travel and
go on trips and stuff whenever they want
maybe I'm left a little bit too much but
then I don't know I don't know I mean we
love watch I have a daughter anything I
love with all my heart and you put money
away and you do this and your that but
you know I have a son you know if he has
drug deaths the guys called his mother
say well such as such owes me money for
this you have to pay him you know this
kid is their little school kids and we
always pay make sure he has his
apartment and stuff and they never have
to never have to worry about it their
struggle for anything and I had no one's
ever given me anything but opportunity
you know and I'm saying this is partly
my fault you know you know what I would
do to a kid like my kid if I saw my kid
if I you think I saw him walk on the
street you know where I would do that
what bad stuff you don't want your kids
on the street I don't know never to
remain you did it not even a little bit
you made a commitment that you so fun
yeah but sometimes I worry maybe they
need they needed a little struggle in
life you know you make a mold along you
make them pay now none do this stuff see
that's me my mother instilled that in me
even her [__] she was a functioning
alcoholic but she wouldn't just give me
a 20 like if I came to this I want that
toy down the block she would all right
sweep the front take the garbage out
wash the bathroom do I gotta clean the
bathroom you gotta clean the bathroom
fill up to be a case and ask Pepe if he
needs help in the kitchen
it would take me and I wanna happen she
drove me in 20 so I knew if I hustled
referred I'm saying like I knew
and that and I was spoiled till my
mother died and then I had to find the
realities of the world
my MA needs to bring her boyfriends over
and really good at bathing if at least
always Roberts pocket remain they can't
support now see always rob doing it
falsely just me robbed a lot of pockets
but they weren't from my mother's but no
my mother died without Chinese the [__]
of my stepfather I love my stepfather
behaviors a loan shark and he would hide
his money in different places in the
house so when I wanted to [__] with him
I would move his money I would never
steal it from him I would move his money
he would never say nothing he would just
go crazy I would do this too and for
[__] weeks and then something
happened between us I went to work for
him selling flowers on 86th Street and
Broadway we would sell gladiolas and one
night I felt he undercut me so I started
robbing for him I like I think a hundred
off the top and he would have his rubber
bands and he would always put like a
marking on him and I would lorem
downstairs one way and I'd make a fire
in the kitchen or something and while he
was turning up I hit him for a hundred I
love bill and one time I never forget I
was robbing him and the hundred olive
dope rubberband blew up and there was
hundreds float and he caught me he's
like you [__]
it was [__] crazy you know this is
when you look around life in your
journey in life you haven't met too many
people like yourself Wow
now I think where I came from
I don't have to do it you know I went
out man what was that I'm in English
reading somewhere and I'm talking to the
young lady I'm young I'm like 23 at the
Times I'm totally young lady and she's
talking about wonderful thing to fire me
data and see what are you doing you're a
young kid oh you're like and I used to
rob people house
there are thousands of that'll snatch
people jury empiricism cell I was so I
didn't get arrested 38 times but you
know and that in that area where I lived
yeah we have police contact but they
were throwing in the back seat of the
car give you a ride home
punch in the stomach you know they would
smack in the face cops were different
back then but the worst thing I did at
that age in the eighth grade people were
moving into the house across the street
from me right Mike and they have a New
York license plate so I knew they had to
go back to New York to get this [__] so
I'm the second load me and my buddies
watch them and I broke into the house
and robbed a couple things but I took
the kids stereo it get out of bad ass
Fisher with some [__] loud punk not
not blob Punk but Fisher speeches and
the eight-track with the cassette and
the thing I mean I was living life it's
75 when I robbed this [__] I'm
like 12 or 13 Wow
they come back they call the police I
got the stereo set up in my bedroom
guess what happen I ended up becoming
friends with the kid I would go to his
house and eat and even come to my house
in the end then he wasn't allowed in my
bedroom for two years we were friends
but I never invited him up there he
would always say I come I never saw you
stereo you don't want to see it then
they moved back to the Bronx they were
Puerto Rican they said [__] New Jersey
oh man [__] JD feel awful Rican there
that Puerto Ricans are all over that
beautiful [__] City bro and now they
got Dominicans up and down
I mean javi are beautiful beautiful
they [__] I love that whole area I'm
excited about going back for a few weeks
it's been a long [__] time since 93
every time I go to New York it's just
for [__] three days like it out there
and to be back there in April and May
the weather's [__] nice no humidity
yet that June [__] that June [__] you
get [__] and kill your mother in that
[__] right that's you and you better be
[__] fine I think is mine I yeah and you
had a sleep with a sheep all the windows
open
and another sheep they'd be that one
behind stuff become hang out on the fire
the fire escape yeah and I think you
were talking about the puerto rico snow
cones do come from the sheet of ice for
the tower or they put Tamarindo and
[__] coca minute yeah all the coconut
is the sherry - sherry coconut bakes you
give an extra quarter and [__] mommy
mommy I think though now the quarter
Oh mr. softy bone mr. softy with mr.
softy came into my life in 1988 until
this day my favorite mr. softy is a
double cone but no a chocolate companies
[__] yeah mr. I still [__] with carve
out I really believe knows me still
knows I buy a Carvel cake every on my
birthday even if it's just me alone
[__] hey Joey everything my room my
room I better than they watching
television I was just saying to myself I
was watching Bobby Brown's every little
step he was young like 19 and I think
why this is my everything where did the
time go
and you know I got old too fast what the
hell happened how fast they go by my and
went too fast one minute you were 20
yeah 33 not even like you you wake up
alone 33 wow that was one of 10 years
ago and then you wake up in your 41 then
48 something else hits you and I walk
around I look at my daughter at dinner
some nights know my other [__] did this
happen
six years ago out of luck that this
happened how many [__] when did she
come from you know who brought her into
this [__] house
so sometimes I call it I call friends
some night to give my daughter get one
of my kids off my job and I forget god I
can call people to help you be good job
I know these people you know with them a
member time goes by so fast
you know you met them you know but you
know they get [__] [__] help you daddy
in this when you were sitting there
that cuts his house at that age of 15
dick and you're gonna pick some becoming
champion did you think about going
around the world eight times like you
had yeah you were dreaming about going
around the world fighting the stuff with
custom stuff dreaming we've made me
agree people hold some good Italian food
[__] some women because of all that
was in back at ya you're [__] Savage
yeah you're like I'm gonna go [__] those
in a woman up [__] that dot right off
the head no listen I went on a trip when
they were friendly
yeah we for like three months I'm off
the French Riviera we started from like
Ibiza Spain and we ended up the boat
there but we kept blowing that both
ended up in the Ukraine when we get
parting from country to country we have
a ball with a stem go for the arm no
Mecca then oh [__] okay the Grand Prix
you been to the Monaco 500 - you bet
your Monica Monica how beautiful is
Monica Monica Liz very beautiful you
know it's like the servant in like a
different kind of country where take
care of itself
right yeah what country didn't you go to
work your journeys oh wait I think where
I want to go I want to go to Iran I am
in Iran I would like to go to Iran and
then I walk in those countries that
haven't been here never know I do buy to
behind it divine what you think of Dubai
I love Dubai Dubai it's really awesome
now you're vegan no no probably now I am
yeah one day when you go to these
countries how do you feel about the food
do you read it and only in American
hotels and stay there you what type of
foods do Chinese food I love Chinese
food Chinese food
China okay I get it what about like you
were in Japan various times would you
think the Japan and that's not too bad
the food who's not too bad I hate
Japanese food what do you feel when you
go to a place like Africa and uh when I
first go that's a little apprehensive
the first time you went yeah how old
were you the first time you worked for
Africa um I wasn't out of the fight I
was champ but um I was apprehensive
because of all the rumors I've heard
about Africa and stuff and all the
things that weren't happy and total
happen on television but when I went
there everything was just brilliant and
beautiful people are beautiful okay he
came back and came back from Egypt like
a week ago what we what kind of rumors
did you hear before you went that was
goodness what kind of rumors did you
hear about the anger the violent and
stuff and um can't be kept we're staying
old tongue I come on Fred the hotel your
life Korea and I'm in South Africa are
you been in South Africa South we're
coming out here and I've been to Egypt I
think someone else please don't we
memory now Nigeria is where the party
goes down that's and I rolled me that's
what I hear that Kenya I thought it was
Nigeria where they have the most
pickpockets like that's the most corrupt
in the [__] run I'm just yes that's
where it all goes down in Nigeria I was
just for it you know I didn't know if
you had been there something no well you
pay me I go anywhere for the doorway
switch mm-hmm well you you guys were
talking about the different kinds of
people you've been in your life yes what
is the what is your reception now
because back then you were heavyweight
champ of the world like the toughest guy
ever and now like not like you're still
him but you're also like oh I'm a comedy
act like you're funny like you're funny
like you know like a sweetheart the only
thing is that funny that people who
never saw me fight know who I am from
watching The Hangover and doing other
things I've just done you know I have
outside the box with my cactus and so
they know me from that but then never
see me box they parent have to tell them
how are the boxes before I was an actor
something in them my dear that's crazy
this is my title it might take an active
no and I either Boxford they don't
understand you know I watched all your
fights I get out of jail I'm putting the
halfway house I'm working at a car wash
as a host and I'll never forget I came
up hot for you a was my second one and a
halfway house and I wasn't allowed rec
time so I miss the bug the Buster
Douglas fight mmm it's like God didn't
let me watch didn't want you to watch
surprised play and the next day I was
[__] like you know hey this was 20
years ago we could talk about this [__]
man you know I'm saying listen to crime
my how more like the next day was the
weirdest thing like God didn't let me
watch my main dog [__] do his thing
how crazy is that
that's why I said you and I have similar
eyes my in a lot of ways but I know I
know that every three years somebody
came into our life that open eyes a
little more my wife this one I met in
2000 you know I met this white chick she
from Tennessee what the [__] does she
know her from you know saying you watch
the [__] Sopranos and then one
night you know what this [__] said to
me like fell in love with you no no no
no I was coked up and she says something
I fall in love with the [__]
that call me up because they see
something and nobody else does you know
what this [__] said to me one
day in the middle of my coke out we got
back she goes I had in your favor I said
I could tell that you were raised
without a mother at that time I had two
options I could have picked her up and
thrown on a [__] window but I went
with option B because she broke me down
like no other [__] broke me down
in eight months you know that's why I
cherished my wife because in one
sentence she changed me as a man
how I had a [__] act from now on I
wasn't acting like a person she said I
was missing somebody's love you ever
have somebody say some way [__] like I
know my wife is gonna do this don't
worry it's gonna be alright we're gonna
be doing movies or write some plays
anything the world's gonna do what the
[__] am I gonna do
and here you are doing podcast yeah I
mean I'm making plans to build the
[__] stadium your show but do it look
trust me
I'm a great believer in luck believe I
believe in luck but I also believe that
we got to get ourselves to that place to
be lucky no I believe the harder you
work the more lucky you are you really
believe that so hard never yeah I
believe that's why I get the ads because
I work harder than anyone I mean when I
went down to your Studios and you would
show me all the things you have planned
I'm like when the [__] is Mike Tyson
gonna [__] find time to do all these
things I'm gonna have no idea about the
Egypt trips I mean you don't stop moving
yes I stay alive I'm looking at you a
shark you work seven days a week do you
not even if I could playing it's let me
go cuz I'm useless I don't work and when
you're not working you're thinking about
the next [__] move yeah afterthe
that's a really intense tart depressing
this stuff what's that
I'm not doing it being idled I'm always
thinking about the next war my mind I
could be looking at you talking to you
that's why I need that I smoked that
reefer for two reasons it's a it's the
only thing I have from my past it's a
teddy bear from my past when I was Jose
Antonio mmm and it was damn when I was
Coco and it's there now when I'm Joey
Diaz you know I'm saying Coco my mother
[__] hobo was named Coco Coco was it
my name given to me by my father before
he died
because of how white my skin was so they
called me inside of a coconut you know I
didn't like it for a long time but I
didn't like Jose Antonio either
Jose Antonio was a cunning [__]
he didn't do drugs but he [__] with
people's heads early aids you know
saying cause Antonia was a stone-cold
hustler Jose Antonio was a kid that from
the age of 7 to 16 he didn't care about
[__] he cared about how to make money
and god I loved his mom's grasp like the
more I could stay away from my mother
and her giving me money the better we
were we had an understanding because if
I took a 20 from my mother I had to take
her [__] even though I still took a
24-month from time to time I had to take
a [__] but I wanted to be
independently free I delivered
newspapers I sold flowers on the corner
he's sick Street
I robbed trains I robbed punks and
knocked on people's doors sold the punks
for $1 apiece I was a one-man [__] I
need to make money machine if I went to
Chinatown Lee you want a t-shirt from
Chinatown a Bruce Lee t-shirt yeah it
costs 1250 no it down it cost $9.99 no
that's the shitty one it costs 1250 I'll
prove it to you I would make 350 on the
transaction I learned how to jump into
the converse and jump into dumpsters and
I would have to get the right sizes and
the shoes because you can't pull a six
and an eight and trying to sell him
[__] for the small 13 because
there were 21 dollars that was Jose
Antonio I was Antonia always had to have
a 40 in his pocket from the age of eight
to seven I bought my first
double-oh-seven knife remember double oh
seven that night that big [__] knife
and devil Oh 700 seven on this
[__] it was gigantic big you
could even put it in your Poppi a [__]
like a butt oh my god you had to put it
in your side pocket you had to figure
out a way how your mom came naw [__] you
[__] it wouldn't fit you sighing it was
a Rambo knife I had one when I was eight
my mother found that knife and next
thing you know I was in cat
school getting beat up by nuns my mother
was like I'm not gonna tolerate you ride
with that [__] night well how are we
the first time you carry the knife so
young ten prowling damn nobody would
understand these stories Mike that's why
I was so you're such a breath a [__]
fresh air today you're an ambassador of
God you know that a trip to think of who
you were first that's all my life
consists of meeting somebody today you a
nice little guy beating somebody get
closer to the mike my life consists of
beating somebody every day this wasn't
my kind of play well he's too big let me
go and get my friend to call them and
walk with Him you are both of us if I
wouldn't look like I'm involved I were
always planning spell look at his
[__] Jesse silhouette you know
I dig that yeah they just drop
alternative charge I understand but you
know he was [__] cuz he had that
little [__] color this yeah II might
wanna jump to one of those eyes of the
McClung busted nose broken [__]
ribcage we always kick you when you down
after the mugging just to make sure you
know I mean that was just amazing that
somebody would do that that's somebody
wouldn't do that nut ball like I told
you before it's called a place called
Hollywood people do [__] now he would
they wouldn't normally do who would suck
an old man's dick to get the movie only
in Hollywood you take your dick on the
Bronx that [__] getting cut off
and then they're gonna take it to the
blood bank and get whatever they can for
it this they'll get $10 an ounce of
blood then she get some age oh you know
how he would kid I was telling Lee last
night I'd only how much would I have to
pay you to stand outside the door at NBC
and for me to walk out past you with a
woman who just ate three quaaludes then
suck your dick oh we're not [__] up
and I grew up on Cosby but you got to be
honest what
other city would that happen where a cop
would look and go that woman's been
[__] in the ass and she took a couple
of sleeping pills
I mean most of the woman that said Cosby
robbed her a raped her set outs inside
the trailer a lot of them said inside
the trailer
how many peed in a trailer and the
trailer on the set how many people that
he have to walk past a woman with to
know what the [__] was going on what how
much do I have to pay you to turn your
head worth 15 an hour and benefits he
must have been really gone for he was
gone for a dog look at the reasons after
Davis he was giving [__] sleeping
pills and [__] they Percy would give you
something like you see what the Russians
did what the Chinese did and what the
Cubans did a bunch of diplomats went to
[__] China and a bunch of diplomats
went to Cuba and they had to leave
because a headaches and now they're
suing the government because the cube is
the planet willing for the Chinese in a
doula for ya and it [__] up with the
head and now that the government saying
no that they have no sufficient evidence
that the Chinese and the Cubans are
using [__] commies have taken over
that's not the point the point I forgot
what the [__] the point was that bong
had had me going what was the point Lee
how they [__] with you what would you
want to do for a paycheck
yeah what you want to do for a paycheck
well Mike Mike what is it like obviously
not assaulting people but when you're at
that level
what like can you can you like explain
what it's like to just walk around and
like go into a store or a rest
like people will just do whatever they
want for like do they do whatever they
want for you or like like what is it
like being at that level I don't know
what did you say something what do you
do I asked me what somebody did to me
what happened like when you walk into an
office or something no I'll say this
I'll be in the street I'm in my car and
I pull up on the corner for you girl I
forget in the car I don't know where she
gets in the car she goes to me somewhere
don't know he's maybe forgetting the car
see it's calm
oh no
that is [__] crazy it's cool listen
mom this is my friend this is crazy you
won't believe it if you see him if you
did not see that you do not believe it
now you could pull up to a girl and this
girl look together like she's a nice
girl but she wouldn't do that stupid
like that let me assure me my friend
laughter they can't believe someone
actually did this yet can't believe ya
might get him again a couple don't think
we were going anything hello like I said
Oh Jay was getting [__] after he
killed that [__] the next day he
had a pentile ready suck his dick God
man thing at them awesome yeah married a
young girl 18 20 year old yeah he's got
seven [__] on hold they were killing
[__] for him like when you got
out of prison how do people treat you
for a while hmm that's interesting or
were you back to Iron Mike like nobody
[__] gave a [__] or we got your own
head a little bit of both but I was
eyeing Mike again pretty cautious you
know that I'm right
I'm pretty cautious but I was still
stupid what was going on in your head
when you came out that people were
looking at you we know I was there that
chip on my shoulder angry yeah I wanted
to see the [__] face [__] you
[__] how long did the end the
last four before you realize a couple of
years I'm cool now yeah that stuff
destroyed me stuff I love this join me
that movie they made my henchman it said
they based it off you hmm
the one with Ving Rhames and Wesley's
yeah that [__] is that [__]
pretty much yeah nobody challenged you
in there no they didn't fly some [__]
do it in from [__] if I need to try
to beat you up his [__] hmm
they were saying that I was hearing dumb
[__] then I heard that movie
like this is based on Mike Tyson being
in [__] jail Ving Rhames playing Mike
Tyson assumption I knew they had a beer
by the way that anybody would ever think
about them and they just had me down he
held me down like that you had low bad
experiences in that know I had listen um
yeah I had one left LM for three years I
was like kind of like the best time I've
had a ball in prison but I had a ball
seriously yeah in which way I had
anything I wanted I had um I got my um
she's much not my teaching her to go to
school in prison I got my teacher
pregnant in prison okay I'm gonna teach
you pregnant prison my friend my phone
to call got the driver to a doctor to
get abortion but I gotta break that
prison so it didn't stop you won't lock
that hmm it really is a crazy [__]
ride white guys yet yes I still had a
little bit money when I locked eyes you
know I didn't have a lot more but I have
enough I mean I was still knocked up so
I can still make things happen when I
was locked up actually put this in them
on the hips and that this and that did
that God sounds like cars out thank God
house you were eaten good in there yeah
whatever I want no one to the chow hall
I'm a food brought to me from the street
I had menu to give me many said what do
you want to eat tonight not say I love
them Chinese foods [__] own no
chicken when you boxing it over there no
you're running around train doing
exercise weights and stuff and that's
when you change religious faiths
yeah but I wasn't Muslim before I want
to put them a people rate and know that
okay what were you raised Catholic
[__] off hey I can't saying that
because you know there's angry care for
this one good Catholics no I I listen I
I'm Catholic I'm still Catholic I just
don't go to church and mingle you know
the saying there's no reason to go to
church and mingle with those [__]
people your feet up so
like then like being king of president
versus like you weren't king of like
when you were 15 or 13 in juvie 38 times
like you didn't do whatever you wanted
then no I am okay you know stuff like
that I know everybody also God for my
neighborhood they were locked up you
know I'm some guys used to see for
mother place like Queens that I brought
the Jimena 42nd Street I pretty much
knew everybody in my gym juvenile time
being like I knew everybody did you go
to a city a lot when you were young all
the time pickpocket time no [__] yeah my
mum you you robbed those perverts and
stuff right yeah 42nd seas we used to do
that to say we go with becoming I go to
me often beat the [__] out of them take
their most perfect should ever call the
cops know those little Peter powers when
you jump Malaya beat them they can't
call the cops it was funny with me I
think that the word got out that they
were getting beat on like the word was
definitely I don't go over there the
people and over there sucking your dick
but they'll beat you to death and [__]
and the guy who got me finally that
[__] me up he was waving down the cops
he was there as their Savior like I was
I went back there I went down on a bad
[__] night
and I tried to suck his dick and he I
didn't take I didn't even follow the the
route you're supposed to take him deep a
little by the tree yeah he tangled to
Charlotte people can still see I took
your monkey here though I took a one
Boulevard East and I smacked him on
suicide bridge and that was my bit I
would have had him by the dirt I
would've come hear him scream nobody
heard him scream the only person who was
screaming was me Mike Tyson when he
unloaded 50 [__] style Mike Tyson
songs in my head he was one of those
aerobic pedophiles and [__] this
[__]
went to the gym and jump rope with candy
in his mouth and he lent me the [__] up
with probably 11 punches and he knew how
to hit Mike because he was going up here
he was going on I was coming from you
[__] me up with a with hooks the next
day it wasn't my lip that was busted on
my nose that was a little [__] up
it's the damage he had done to my head
my head leaving my head looked like
Zombo let me tell you something there
was a guy down there so hot dogs that
weighed 500 pounds and he made fresh
lemonade
I was I was down at three times a week
eating those dirty dog I thought after
that [__] pedophile beat me I never
went back down there again not even to
get a hot dog cuz I was scared he was
still waiting for me yeah I got jumped I
got it was a it was a mugging that was a
[__] uh it was it backfired on me
might you ever have a mugging backfire
on you hey listen man I'm gonna tell you
hit me you gotta hit me what you know
and somebody got killed one of my
friends got killed
oh my god yeah mugging oh man
so the mugger shot one of our friends
like and he was like Berkowitz the crazy
Jew no no one on the train that time in
New York that guy with jury on them and
stuff and um nobody searched me it's all
the jury and it went for the jury no I
decided search this guy nothin stuff
when everybody started to turn they like
walked around town I came out boom boom
I would have [__] my [__] pants my
buddies went to get their dick sucked
one night in New York and I was
downstairs I was not a gettin but it
sucked the type of guy and buildings and
[__]
and they went upstairs with these two
chicks they wanted to a building I was
down there for 45 minutes I was supposed
while they would get met dick sucked I
was supposed to go around the corner and
cop it was right when you get off the
George Washington Bridge and make a left
this little Dominican built back then
those buildings the cops had that wired
down they knew why you were there nobody
bought you a little bodega on the corner
so if it was me you and Mike Mike's
gonna get his dick sucked
I'm gonna get the drugs you've all this
six-pack to buy daily news and a pack of
gum maybe some [__] chicharonnes just
to have a reason to be there
and then we don't meet downstairs we let
the [__] two idiots go upstairs
forty-five minutes later they went to
get their dick suck now I got a buzz my
way into the building cuz it's also the
drug dealer building and go back
upstairs and look for these two idiots
and I finally something something made
me go on the roof the door was open and
both these idiots were handcuffed the
chick [__] he they said the story was
the chick was sucking one of their dicks
and while she went to suck the other
guy's dick a guy came up on the roof and
said what do we have here get up here
I'm gonna stick of all it was a [__]
fake sticker put him up handcuffed him
told him he was the cop to call this
[__] and left him that one of the
Dominicans to get a [__] we had a
[__] open up the handcuffs and the
two guys made me promise never to tell
the story that's the first time I told
it the guy's name was teacher bus
station his buddy and they got their
dick sucked over there and I didn't you
know that's why I don't like going I
mean another time I went over there my
buddy got his dick sucked this time he
kidnapped the [__] we took him back to
Jersey and robbed it for $60 a little
wig on fire man we used to have a white
guy he would listen he wasn't white but
he when he was put anything but white he
had blue eyes blond hair and everything
he's always just put up the jury honor
to put him in the front of the movie
there's up there for people to [__] when
we can [__] them up again fight where
would you hide huh where would you hide
that would be very him he made a friend
behind stuff fights I think they think
you do I wasn't robbed it's amazing
where you been tally goes when you're
street my 8th my sup my senior year I
wasn't even in high school I had already
quit but I was still hanging out with
those guys I was working and we went to
the city we picked up a baby crying yeah
we're always plotting I'll never forget
that I went to [__] we went picked up
an eighth born on the 35th and AM said
we went to my buddy's forefathers
jewelry liquor store it was closed at
10:00 we broke into it he had the key in
the alarm codes she took out my with
Jack in a case of nips the hate outs
cold beers and we started drinking them
or with us bla we were [__] up Mike -
catching Picard local 1000 calling
declaring well how old were you from
like 10 11 12 - oh Jesus Christ Mike I
well I started out light with Boone for
any serious yeah I started what's that
going Jim yeah oh Jesus Christ
straight or with little Tommy where's my
wine [__] straight and one of while I
was Roble wild Irish Rose in Thunderbird
I remembered that should give you a
headache for days you think that Doug
the bird will give you a headache for a
to kill you man that [__] will [__]
kill you what's the word then the bird
the bird commercial that was there that
was the slang on the stream okay that
was on the street dog what up G what's
the word and under bird I'm in I got 50
Cent's and I got a nickel Lee got a
dollar
let's go we'll get some potato chips
going deadly silent on your tab remember
well you can run a tab at the bodega
does listen mummy did this you come
there and you give them a food stamp
right but they don't give no changes
right selling paper only 70 cents
variety cents yeah and it's good that
[__] would crack me because I was food I
would buy food stamps like 30 cents to a
dollar are you buy people's family
problem that junkies so when they're $60
with the food stamps you've met with the
Yohan just robbed for my food stand yeah
in cash you can cast expecting even
cashed my check for oh it was so easy
back in the seventies thought my biggest
scam was you know 70 Freud you didn't
have to have the information you'd have
the check different I was a different
world trip don't tell him
Chinese restaurants used to go in and
there yeah in print the card that's so
you spent over 50 they never rang
I go to the same Chinese for money for
freedom what rice and gravy well he's
always giving out in the street hustler
stuff I couldn't eat until I'll go there
buy some rice and gravy
if you eat Chinese restaurant you know
what else I made a lot of lawyer you
know you know I took down single and
tell me about it
oh man that's tricky so you gotta go too
far in neighborhoods for me you gotta go
to jab ville the handle Japanese rapper
but they don't ask questions you don't
tell no lies let's say you got a $50
[__] American Express traveler's check
you buy some 43230 too late no ID okay
they give you 18 and change you follow
me so you would just go to Japan ville
and spend a little bit they were all in
on it because they got the insurance
nobody gave a [__] so if I knew you were
going on vacation you said to me I go
what are you gonna do how much you got
well I'm kind of struggling I only got a
thousand forget about it go to the bank
get me the traveler's checks bring them
to me
call the police say you got them stolen
file a police report you go right back
to the back within one hour you get your
traveler's checks back and I'll give you
five off the top so I make five hundred
you make five hundred so what you catch
a little smack to the face like Henry
Hill says everyone so why you gotta get
a beatin sometimes yeah that's it
sometimes a fire somewhere along your
way
I think I know the answer to this but
like how many days a week Mike were you
thinking about doing all this stuff like
was it every every day yeah it was my
job I get me the monocle I go to school
eat breakfast and then with some class
stuff with my guava and stuff Robin is
doing lunchtime come come back won't eat
lunch if I didn't get a good thing but I
gotta get thing I eat let's go somewhere
else in the restaurant like Red Lobster
somewhere yeah rather than that I come
to school I come back to school on time
II go back out again till five o'clock
it's magnified good after that it's
really not going to get any more hits
unless you run up a rob someone
god bless you look you're that wine let
me ask you a question
when your mentality because I know this
I have to be honest of people so I'll
tell you there was a day there was days
when I would wake up from the ages of 17
to 27 and I would wake up and go I don't
know how the day is going to start don't
know how it's gonna end
what I do know is that I got to come up
with 18 hours cuz I need money to eat I
gotta do laundry and I gotta have a bag
of dope um
and somewhere another I get 82 or I get
75 and that's in the song from the
stones comes on you can't always get
what you want but then something
happened years later that mentality went
from waking up so how am I gonna rob
today it became I'm waking up where am I
gonna get on stage that that
transference happened for you from
robbing to boxing did you fall in love
so much with boxing then it took you
away from that you had that 100% 100%
you went from thinking about I saw your
interview one time say that when you
stayed with us at night you would watch
fights endlessly black and white fights
endlessly you studied the good listen I
have all the utmost respect for all your
accomplishments but my overall most
respect for you is that nobody can ever
pull one over on you about a fighter if
there's a fighter that existed good or
bad you know he existed you know the
date he fought moving forth
was that how many tickets were sold and
that impresses me to know him with you
when I saw you do that interview I had
just gotten into comedy and I said if he
was a champion and he studied all those
tapes it's time for me to study tape
some guys that have nothing to do with
me even if I don't like comedy just to
see everything that was available to me
that's the best thing to study I was
thinking if I'm moving in if I'm gonna
get involved in anything Saints baseball
boxing
oh yes the record is anything I'm gonna
find out who'll be who
this first began go to the origin of it
where first began and I know the plays
are and I'm gonna know how to play the
game I'm know how it feels for him I
felt for him have one love for him
that's not what and you study the
fighters and you study what they did
what they didn't do what made them
successful what you're gonna do
different you know what kid chocolate
did this type of training I'm gonna do
that time but really I wanted to say
something to you about that I was
lieutenant about get chocolate and I was
talking to you about
he was got single disease but but he did
it was bigger than that here he made
people he turned people in the fighters
he said Joe Lewis would've been a
fighter Henry Armstrong they wouldn't
have been fighters in there much money
he made they had nothing in they had no
intention in mind becoming a fighter
they were people in to play violin and
y'all started working on the railroad
and he saw on the paper I was get
chocolate made like I'm I don't know
85,000 dollars a night one night they
said [__] this I won't be a fighter he
inspired so many great fighters and then
say that what did you like the most
about his fighting style he's beautiful
the pretty fighter Muhammad Ali he's
different timekeepers guys definitely
move the shoulder they played about the
difference of a rose bongo plays goes
bonkers look pretty good-looking with
ballet players you know their belly
dances it's amazing that I learned a lot
from being Mike we're very similar and
now we smoke weed with three hands you
don't give a [__] jack
I know I like to smoke and you love your
[__] re4 now just so nobody [__]
gets in your way there's no
misunderstandings so what's next for
Mike Tyson brother fill me in cool in
church on what's next beside being a
[__] great inspiration oh really what
I'm doing that I ain't balked on my
canvas business and not necessarily from
a flower perspective you know we'll work
with Flo we don't necessarily touch it
but for us even a DVD perspective you
know from the medicine perspective
from the health perspective hygienic
hygienic perspective you love CBD off
and yeah I think it's the miracle oil me
to responsibly have responsive and I
love everything about them I've tried
several people have sent me pounds of
[__] and there's an ointment that I
really like I like their room and I like
that tincture and I like that gummy
bears you know so we I would never met
some of the people I've gotten become
friendly with some of the people you
mean so if it wasn't from the weed
perspective you know from dill kind of
cannabis and stuff no a lot of people
what the [__] is that Liberace Kong yeah
Jesus Christ he's back to the grave okay
listen Mike I appreciate you coming up
here today I know it's a long route no I
thought good man I friendship where'd
you go we mean it was really all about
potato tacos you should finally die so
what do you eat with he transmits pretty
much egg white and broccoli or spinach
sometimes that your breakfast egg white
with brownies
yeah you got either yolk from time to
time but good my weight bearing is boom
what are you looking at drop it Charlie
forty pounds
really what are you walking around it
now I don't know party to six you look
beautiful way and nobody I want to be
healthy you just have a physical lately
or something no but I just know I by the
end sometime I'm one of those guys I
just got get to present you see [__]
away and start eating and say I hate
myself or something and they have to
suffer and lose the way when you get the
cannabis corn
are you gonna sell cannabis and stores
will I be able to distribute to those
people in the store then they're gonna
sell the cannabis all the cannabis know
what's it gonna be called Tyson's
knockout that could be some of them as
well yeah I want you to get me hey old
cush you know as yeah way to give me
like a twin is
called Coco's debt and smoke this [__]
you ain't coming back a legend I think
Coco's debt you know I'm saying the
return of Coco the Kush you the
concussions from Coco like best thing
about you man I tell you what I've done
a lot of podcasting John or whatever
more questions everywhere I've gone the
last three weeks people have asked me or
what type of person you're on I'm gonna
tell me like the holy moly you're a
champion in and out of the ring
and what you doing for people you smile
you know Tom Segura wrote a bit about
your meet you're on airplane it's on
Netflix you're just that back
[__] John put on this video we
always see people with you that's well I
know that that's it that's all I keep it
I bet the dog I revisit the scary people
I don't give a [__] another Subaru
nobody needs to know nothing they can
all suck my dick and call me shorty I
was born in 1940 Mike just break that
talent jesus christ almighty Mike I love
being 40 shorty from 1940 [__] around
that's an old Broncos head from Tremont
Avenue all the way with the Royal
javelins used to running [__] whenever
your first gang Charlie stompers jolly
[__] stuff yeah what was your insignia
Mike Tyson I believe to see you on your
podcast
I'll see you I love them whatever you
want me I'll be down I'll go down there
and [__] rock with you for an hour or
two fair and it's concert what is the
next concert over we're at a little bit
Palm Springs
what's it gonna be called hot spring
there will be the kind festival Mike I'm
tightening ransom for the kind you're
gonna have comedy show we got four
hundred and ten acres
oh [__] we've got a lot of people there
yeah they just got to get some bathrooms
people don't have to
it's literally like Woodstock I get it
country get up some coffee shop they
make it what the coffee stuff magic
Starbucks with a party charlie working
at Starbucks out there like I wish you
all the luck in the world you may know
it's very grateful you do a lot of love
and they like to turn that good for me
yeah yeah I'm really happy to has to MIT
I mean you got more lives than a
[__] cat
but you always welcome here I love you
have a great day stay black all day and
most important stay beautiful you see
justice Millette bit sad slap that knows
you gotta cover this [__] I love you
Mike Tyson thank you very much a
kilometer chase today I want to give
Mike a shout-out for stopping by they
the champ a champs I want to give the
Christ killer a shout-out always showing
up and [__] with his little bald head
doing no [__] for they'll bid but
most importantly I want to thank you
guys remember next weekend I'm in
Pittsburgh only Thursday night ten
o'clock tickets left and the 19th in
Minneapolis at the Fitzgerald theater
and 420 the first shows already sold out
so get your tickets because they're
gonna go fast - at the Pabst Blue Ribbon
Peeta
I'd like to thank our sponsors today I
want to start with zip recruiter this
hiring is challenging but there's one
place you can go we're hiring is simple
fast and smart a place with growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiter
dot-com / Church hiring used to be hard
multiple job site stacks of resumes up
it's a confusing review process but
today hiring can be easy and only have
to go to one place in one place only
that's zip recruiting calm why they send
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with the powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scan thousands
of resumes as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights a top candidate for you so
you never grace you miss a great match
that means saving you time time is money
zip McCool is so effective you ready for
this one that 80% of the employers who
post
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within one day one day
do me a favor right right now the church
listen this can go to zip recruit and
try it for free at zip recruit coms last
Church again that's zip recruiter
dot-com slash Church
si-hu rch zip recruited dot-com slash
church the church is brought to you four
by four hymns listen why are you guys
trying to wid solutions or do nothing
when you could turn to medicine and
science maybe you found that ball stop
ball spot maybe your headline starting
to recede maybe you wanna do some about
it well for hems comm is one-stop
shopping for hair loss skin care and
sexual wellness for men listen I'm
losing my hair right now but I'm 56 but
if I was 30 and ice noticed something
I'd get on four hens calm right now the
plumbing the plumbing is working fine
but as far as you young guys the
plumbing starting to deteriorate listen
knock it off no more awkward in-person
doctor visits or long Pharmacy lines all
right for hims connects you with real
doctors online and real doctors who can
save you hours completely confidential
and discreet what you do is you answer a
few questions the doctor reviews it and
if you determine and they determine
what's right for you they prescribe a
medication to treat hair loss that is
shipped directly to your door nobody
knows about nothing get the hair loss
treatment everybody's talking about I
mean this is featured in GQ Men's Health
Esquire Playboy just to get the party
started just to name a few
what I'm gonna do right now is this I'm
giving you a solid order now today and
the church family you get started with a
for hims complete Hecate for just fine
hours this is cost you thousands I'm
talking about five hours while supplies
last and subject to doctor's approval
restrictions apply but you got to see
the website for details like I said this
could cost you hundreds if you went to a
doctor or pharmacy somewhere I'll save
time go to for hems coms last Joey again
that's fo r hims comm slash Joey they
gotta take hit carry tommy uncle Joey
sent you right and last but not least
one of my favorite products that I've
been counted
last couple years you know why because
it works I'm 56 I try to work out I'd do
a couple drops every night I sleep like
a baby I wake up the next morning
refreshed and that CBD lion calm because
listen picking a reliable CBD companies
are paying the [__] ass no more with
CBD line calm
they make CBD products from start to
finish and CBD line - you're covered
whether you want to vape whether you
want to do the cartridges whether you
want to shadow you're not into smoking
[__] that they got gummy bears the
delicious and I think [__]
that's the [__] die for you put it
under your tongue you're moving around
for 30 seconds and bam let me tell you
something through two hours a day you
could do whatever the [__] you want like
a salve it's plus their products are
clean Bobby and they are like the takes
that these that they [__] with the
false advertisements and whatnot CBD
line is the source for CBD go to CBD
line calm right now and check out their
third party lab results you're gonna
[__] fall off your chair I mean when
I got the brochure and I went through
with these people [__] care they
really care they'll break it down for
you what you need what it controls what
an attacks CBD lion calm right now the
church family gets 20% off use Church at
checkout alright that's it and that's
that have a great [__] weekend
and remember uncle Joey loves you right
stay black kick this [__] meal leave